wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like EES dropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn why 5% of people control the
world's wealth how to make money with
gold the best assets to invest in and
how to analyze companies to find the
winners get ready to learn about how
wealth is created and get the strategies
and how to do it from millionaires
enjoy hello again Patrick gentempo here
and welcome back for episode seven of
wealth breakthroughs today we have a
rock solid onew punch for you about the
world of precious medals let's start at
the top in times of economic crisis the
dollar tends to fall in gold Rises then
when hard times give way to economic
recovery gold Falls in price and the
dollar bounces back but what if it
didn't what if some event or series of
events fundamentally changed the economy
forever could gold go to $5,000 $110,000
an ounce or more we're kicking off
episode 7 with one of the world's most
famous widely read widely quoted and
knowledgeable gold experts Jim Rickards
then we'll talk to Adam barata who
traces Gold's historic significance to
our monetary system this is going to be
a good one let's get started here's Jim
[Music]
Rickards so Jim thank you so much for uh
for being here I've been looking forward
to getting a chance to talk to you so
tell me a little bit about who you are
and and what you do well uh that's a
really good question uh you know who I
am uh uh I've had a a long career and if
I described it all in detail you would
say either I uh you could say I was
eclectic or I didn't know what I want to
be when I grew up but uh uh after um uh
College I uh went to uh got a graduate
degree in international economics then I
got a law degree um and I decided once
was on enough so I got a second law
degree uh specializing in taxation and
started my career at City Bank and I was
International tax council at City Bank
this is a back when it was a bank before
it turned into a hedge fund which
happened a lot a lot later uh but in the
late 70s and early 80s when I was there
I mean City Bank was um you we thought
kind of Wall Street was sort of sleazy
but banking was a high Prestige
occupation we were Walder wristen was
the CEO at the time he treated City Bank
like the Finance arm of the state
department so whether you know we were
in Africa or Latin America Asia you know
Etc all over the world I was in the
international side um I was the number
two guy in our particular division we
had Asia Africa Middle East um and
Australia and so my boss got to go to uh
you know Tokyo and Sydney and Singapore
and I got to go to the Congo and uh you
know Tanzania and ner and places like
that that would be hard to find on the
map but it was a good experience and uh
you eventually worked my way up and got
to go to the uh the more attractive
cities but I you know learned a lot
about Africa and enjoyed the time there
um after about 10 years of that I uh
it's unusual for a tax laer to switch
gears because it's so specialized takes
so much training so much education when
you get good at it like why on Earth
would you walk away from it you just do
it for the rest of your career and um
that's what my colleagues did we still
have these little reunions every now and
then but uh had the opportunity to to
move to Wall Street join a an investment
bank that um specialized in in
government securities government bond
trading I did that 1985 I was their
general counsel uh you know the chief
legal officer and uh that was my
immersion in uh Federal Finance fiscal
policy and the bond market um at at City
Bank which I was a tax lawyer but we
were mainly involved in international
lending uh but now I was involved in the
Securities market and this was right
around the time when derivatives were
taking off I mean you've had you know
Exchange traded Futures in Chicago since
the late 19th century so there's nothing
new about that about you know exchange
traded Futures but over the counter
swaps credit default swaps you know
exotic derivatives that was all new and
it was all being kind of made up as we
went along today it's there are trade
organizations and standardized forms and
you just fill in the blank but in those
days you had to kind of start with a
blank sheet of paper and construct these
contracts and we did and I I wasn't the
trader but I was the lawyer and I worked
side by side with Traders you had to
understand the trade to write the
contract so uh that was a you know as I
say great education and an exciting time
because it was all new and markets were
expanding uh did that until um the early
90s uh and uh then U saw the hedge funds
starting up um the coming out of Solomon
Brothers Solomon Brothers is kind of a
uh you know an ancient name today but in
the day they were the biggest bad as
number one bond trading firm uh by far
they were subsequently absorbed by City
Bank um
but they had a they had a scandal one of
their Traders was a bad apple actually
tried to Corner the market into your
treasury nutes if you can believe that
not not easily done completely illegal
but he managed to pull it off but it got
exposed at some point and he ended up
behind bars but as a result a lot of top
people at Solomon were either uh you
know Terminator just forced to resign
they weren't all bad guys uh and one of
them was John Merryweather who was their
top Bond trader John didn't know
anything wrong that's very clear but um
given the magnitude of the problems in
the firm uh he had to leave so was we
say you know you on the beach for six
six months or whatever that's the
expression on Wall Street uh he launched
a hedge fund called uh long-term Capital
Management uh but what he did he
recruited a lot of his former colleagues
from Solomon Brothers as well as leading
academics when I say leading we had two
Nobel Prize winners um um Bob Merton of
Harvard and Myon scholes uh scholes has
his name attached to the black sches
formula which is the formula for pricing
all derivatives you can show me the
fanciest most layered complicated
derivative ever done and I can show you
that at the bottom of that is an option
uh or a series of options or set of
options that are priced using the black
shs formula myin used to say uh he
actually published this article as an
academic and kind of threw it out there
was like E eal mc squ here's the formula
if you want to understand the universe
he said with hindsight I should have
patented it and charged a fraction of a
penny on every uh derivative I would be
the richest guy in the world which is
probably not uh not too far from the
truth but be that as it may we had the
the founders uh theoretical Founders the
academic founders of modern Financial
Theory not all of them but a lot of them
uh so many in fact that there were there
were times while while I was at
long-term Capital Management when we got
calls from The deans of the leading
business schools in the country I'm
talking about Harvard Chicago Stanford
um Yale and a few others um complaining
that we were hiring so much PhD Talent
we were depriving Academia of the next
generation of Scholars because they were
all coming to work for us but it was an
exciting time we made uh we started with
a billion dollars we got to S billion
dollars in four years um some of that
was new money but a lot of it was kind
of tripling the investor money we were
banging out 25 35 one year 40 uh percent
returns using these very complex
arbitrages and so now I wasn't in
Investment Banking I was in hedge funds
uh but the knowledge I learned in
government securities was still relevant
because we were we were the number one
Trader in Italian government debt one of
the largest traders in US Government
debt one of the largest uh presence um
uh participants on the major Futures
exchanges not just Chicago but Paris uh
Tokyo London um you know major Financial
Centers around the world um we had the A
Team um I'll never forget the day when
the Nobel prizes were awarded to our two
partners and they were both out uh that
day so all the calls I had to handle all
the calls I did did the pr and people
you know media calling from all over the
world and flower tributes showing up in
the lobby we're like hey Minon where are
you you know you got to we got to deal
with this but it was it was an exciting
time then in uh June of uh 20 sorry
1997 um the government of Thailand uh
broke the peg between their currency
that Tai bot and the US dollar and
closed their capital account and why was
that significant well they had been
maintaining a peg between the tibot and
the US dollar uh and had an open Capital
account which meant that money could
come in and go out pretty freely so
money was coming in the tibot offered
higher returns than um us interest rates
so you could borrow cheaply in dollars
convert to bot invest in Thailand golf
courses Resorts hotels whatever it was
and make these huge returns and just
look like free money well it turned into
a boom uh then it uh burst and the
bubble burst uh and Thailand closed the
capital account where there were massive
losses as a result of that because all
these US dollar investors all of a
sudden their taii bbot were worth a lot
less than US dollars they were suffering
losses so investors panicked they said
well if tand did it you know we've lost
money there what about Indonesia
Malaysia uh South Korea you know Etc
countries around South Asia so there
started this began this massive Capital
outl everyone was just selling
everything getting their money out out
uh you know wall streeters use the
Expression you know blood in the streets
don't buy anything till there's blood in
the streets know it was when the market
was at a low well there was real blood
in the streets people were getting
killed in Jakarta and and and so South
Korea and elsewhere um that lasted from
June until kind of the late fall October
November then around December it calmed
down a little bit the IMF came in did
some rescues governments intervene
capital accounts were closed the losses
were suffered but the whole thing seemed
to die down a little bit bit and by the
spring of
1998 we were looking around for
opportunities they say you know things
have been knocked down maybe there's a
way to invest here we were continuing to
do what we had always done with the um
the bond Arbitrage and uh you know it
could be um uh a Japanese stock index
except against Japanese U stock index
futures or a basket of uh French
equities against French stock market
index Futures uh but even the equities
uh that we owned we in derivative form
we'd buy these Total return swaps from
be Sterns so be Sterns would buy the
stocks and then sell us the derivative
so they were you know long the stocks
short the the swap but economically that
was a hedge position and they'd make a
little spread on that uh and uh so you
know life went on but bye uh but there
were other things going on one of which
was that we had um it's called Secret
Sauce we we had formulas that that John
muray than the team actually invented
they were the first people to really
think about the math Behind These
Arbitrage trades where you'd have you
know short the bonds and go long the
futures or vice versa uh and but little
by little you over time other people
started to figure out the formula so all
of a sudden we had Banks and others
piggybacking on our trades number one
and number two around this time Sandy
wild U one of the leading bankers at the
time who ran uh travelers insurance they
bought Solomon Brothers and then he got
in talks with John Reed to merge with
City Bank and right around this time the
glass Sagle talk the late 90s they were
getting ready to repeal the glal act so
John Reed and Sandy W announced this
merger well prior to the merger Sandy
wild said to Solomon Brothers these are
the the place this is the place John
weather left but Solomon stayed in the
business he said hey we want you guys to
reduce your books because one of the
things about this Arbitrage I'm
describing it was very you could lose a
lot of money in in in a quarter and then
make it all back and then sum the
following quarter and this because these
were spread trades so if the spreads
went out like this You' actually buy
more and then they would come in like
this and you'd make all your money back
a little bit like doubling down in
roulette if you do it long enough and
you have enough money you'll make your
money back um but uh sandal didn't like
that volatility he he was thinking the
stock price you know stock investors are
not going to like that volatility so he
said close your books and get out of
these trades when they did that widen
the spread so all of a sudden here we
are in our what turned out to be a
little bubble in Greenwich Connecticut
uh we think the Asian financial crisis
is over but it's not uh we think these
spreads have to be well behaved but
they're not uh and then it all blew up
uh beginning in uh in the summer really
uh July August uh 1998 and then came to
a head in September and the the bottom
line is that um Russia defaulted um it's
one thing to default on your external
Deb but Russia actually defaulted on
their internal debt which is in Rubles
like hey you can print rubles why would
you default on the ruble debt if you can
print them but they did anyway and they
and they broke the currency Peg that
started a Global Financial panic and now
uh the best definition of a panic I've
ever heard is um everybody wants their
money back you know whatever trade you
range just sell it give me my money back
I don't care about relative value I
don't care about presentent value I
don't care about all your math just give
me my money back when that happens to
spread just wide well we were short the
volatility we made our money by selling
the volatility and getting paid for that
uh in the expectation the reasonable
expectation that the volatility would
widen and then it would come in again
well now it just kept going it kept
going and then so August we lost $2
billion which was about half our Capital
at the time we had 7 billion at the end
of 90 uh 97 but we gave three billion
back all cash dividend to investors so
most of the investors did fine believe
it or not the people lost the money we
were the ones who lost the money because
we were kind of replacing own investors
um so in August we lost two billion it's
about half our Capital we were talking
to uh George Soros Warren Buffett um you
anyone you could a short list of people
who can write a billion dollar check but
we we were in touch with them um and uh
but we knew that um by early September
literally September 2nd we report
monthly we we tell our investors what
happened and and we did we were you know
completely compliant there was no um no
no funny business uh our accounting was
extremely good we knew exactly how much
we were losing um so September 2nd we
released our August statement and in
those days we were still using fax
machines and we didn't quite have the
the internet the way it is today and I
had about 50 faxes uh to send out and I
commandeered like six or seven fax
machines and I had all my legal
assistants you know sending these out
before the last fax was sent the first
one had been leaked to Bloomberg and it
was public knowledge to the world now it
it changed the Panic continued but it
wasn't a general liquidity crisis it was
systematic trading against long-term
capital it's it was blood in the water
you end up as the uh the Marlin and the
old man of the sea I mean they're just
coming for you uh and the way Wall
Street operates it's like why should we
cut you a break why should we invest in
you we'll just drive you into bankruptcy
and then we'll pick up the pieces on the
cheap no one's nobody's doing anybody
any favors and we we knew that but we
were trapped um so around mid-september
we called the Federal Reserve we didn't
expect a bail out we didn't ask for a
bailout who who the heck's going to bail
out a hedge fund we we knew that wasn't
going to happen but we felt uh we had
some obligation like good corporate
citizens like hey you're the Federal
Reserve this is going to end up in your
lab we want to tell you what's going on
uh and uh so the FED came up on a Sunday
was Peter fiser who was the head of open
market operations at the Federal Reserve
Bank of New York Dino C his associate
Gary Gensler from the treasury in
Washington myself and John Maryweather
so the five of us just sat in a
conference room on a Sunday for hours
you know turning the pages the printouts
going through position by position and
when we were done I looked at Peter and
Peter fiser and his face was white and
he said we knew you guys were going to
destroy the bond market we didn't know
you were going to destroy the stock
market also it turned out we had5
billion dollars of equity positions on
we were the largest Fisk Arbitrage from
nobody knew that cuz they we your bond
shop no we were we were in equities also
um and just to kind of go back to my
bear Stern's example if bear you know
buys the stocks and then sells them to
us in derivative form and they have a
hedge position but we go away we just F
from we just disappear well now you're
long $5 billion worth of stocks what do
you do you dump them imagine all of Wall
Street trying to dump you know 5 10
billion dollars of stocks in the same
morning it would have closed every
Market in the world so at that point
Peter fiser went back had breakfast the
next morning with John Corine who was
head of Goldman BS uh the head of umero
Lynch U JP Morgan you know three or four
of the biggest banks and said we have to
do something they weren't out to do us
any favors they were out to save
themselves because we had 1.3 trillion
dollar of swaps on with the 50 largest
banks most of which were concentrated
into about 14 or 15 Banks so they didn't
really care about us but again if you
take us out of the equation all those
Banks were going to fail Leman brothers
would would have failed 10 years before
they actually they were always the weak
Link in the chain um and so they talked
a couple days sent us a term sheet on a
Wednesday night from Wednesday to Sunday
nobody slept uh we got um scatter arms
is a big Law Firm they nobody was in
charge and I was in charge of our side
from the from the legal perspective but
nobody was in charge of what was came to
be known as the Consortium these 14
Banks I call them the 14 families uh
because they were they didn't trust each
other you know it's kind like the mafia
in that sense uh but they acted out of
self-interest put this bailout together
um and said well we give you 4 billion
in cash because they were going to take
over the fund they they say this was not
charity uh we would have suffered our
losses but the idea was to stabilize the
balance sheet and unwind it gradually
over the course of a year so that you
didn't have to do it all at once um and
um so we as say 5 days no sleep it's
funny at the law firm we were working 24
hours a day start out first thing you
know the jackets come off you know then
the ties come off and then like shirts
are you know unbuttoned down here
nobody's shaving um there's 24-hour
catering so you could be getting a meal
at at you know 3: in the morning
whatever um hundreds of lawyers flying
in you because you had 14 Banks but
every bank had a general counsel a
deputy an outside Law Firm partner
probably two Associates um so we five or
six lawyers per Bank times the 14 Banks
plus some other unsecured creditors it
was a scene um
but I remember at one time uh I was in
line just you know got a sandwich or
whatever and somebody came up to me and
grabbed my arm and said are you gym
records I said yeah and they go how are
you holding up like I mean there were
literally people passing out that the
stretchers were called in I mean it was
it was high stress and um fortunately no
one died but there were some people who
were hospitalized actually I said how
are you holding up through this and I
had just come from uh an expedition to
climb Denali then mount McKinley in
Alaska and I had been training like
crazy and it's an extremely difficult
climb and I said well I just got back
from climbing to nollie so far this is
not harder than that so it was a good
thing I was in good shape uh in other
words but we got through it um and uh
then we I stayed for about a year after
that my metaphor was you know if you
blow up the chemistry lab you're
supposed to clean up before your next
class uh but I had had enough fun uh in
that uh particular Pursuit and left and
um I ran an electronic Stock Exchange uh
for a few years uh but then uh then 9/11
came um and uh not long after 911 I was
tapped uh I was actually at a cocktail
party in St Croy on a mountain top
estate kind of a you know pretty exotic
little C looked like a set from a James
Bond movie or something but um you know
you chat with people and they ask you
what you did what you do whatever and I
I don't know why but I just started
telling a story about how now I'm going
all the way back to the early 80s when Z
AL hook the president of
Pakistan um it was after the Iranian
Revolution in 1979 but Pakistan had
declared itself to be the first Islamic
Republic but Iran said we're the Islamic
Republic uh so Zia said well I've I've
got out Islam you know Iran to maintain
my stature he declared just out of the
blue that all banks in uh Pakistan had
to be Sharia compliant Sharia is Islamic
law well Sharia compliant means no
interest uh you're not allowed to charge
interest how do you run a bank if you
can't charge interest so uh again this
is back in the early 8s so I was put in
charge of converting City bank Pakistan
we had a huge operation in Pakistan and
I was put in charge of converting City
bank Pakistan to Islamic banking um and
so I had to become an expert in Islamic
banking which I did and we did the
conversion some of it was cosmetic but
the government was okay with it and we
we got through that so here I am now
flesh forward 2002 in s Cy at this
cocktail party meeting with one of the
biggest investors in the world and um I
just tell this Pakistan story out of the
blue so he looks around he takes me
aside and walk over and he says uh if
you got a call from the CIA to help them
out uh in the war on terror would you
take the call and would you be
interested in something like that I said
of course I would I mean know in those
days you know the no one thought twice
about helping out the United States or
doing whatever you could well uh you
know sure enough I got the call and I
said yeah let me you I'll do what I can
and I got a letter kind of an engagement
letter and uh went down to CIA
headquarters in Langley and it was a it
was a symposium kind of format they were
working on something called project
prophecy uh interesting name but just
the the long and short of it is there
was insider trading before 911 and it's
well documented it's mentioned in the
9/11 commission report uh it's not some
conspiracy Theory it it happened it was
uh 286 times the average daily volume in
puts buying a put is a bet that the
Stock's going to go down uh 286 times
the average daily volume in American and
United Airlines in the last two trading
days before 911 well those were the two
airlines that were hijacked it's like a
guy orders a cheeseburger for lunch
every day and one day he orders 286
cheeseburgers you know something's up uh
there's something behind it uh and it
was really up to the FBI and the SEC to
investigate that for forensic point of
view but the interest of the
intelligence Community was okay that
happened if there were if there were
going to be another spectacular
terrorist attack and everyone was just
waiting for one at that point um would
there be inside of trading again could
you detect it in advance trace it to the
source get a fisa warrant break down the
door and stop the attack and save lives
that was the idea behind project
prophecy but before you implement
something like that you study it and say
well are all of those things true and
the CIA had no Financial expertise
inside and and why should they the the
capital markets had not been part of the
battle space during the Cold War they
had economists who would like estimate
the GDP of Russia and they never got it
right but uh but in terms of capital
markets and trading they didn't have
that expertise and I will say they're
very good at uh reaching out when uh
they they know what they don't know and
they're very good at reaching out so I
went down um participated and then they
said by the way we have a secure website
we invite people ble to contribute
articles I wrote an article it was very
well received uh one thing leads to
another and next thing you know I was a
co- project manager working for the
agency on Project prophecy and we were
we invented a new branch of intelligence
uh in intelligence lingo use the word
int the int uh suffix in as a form of
intelligence so there's human which
means human intelligence uh signant
which is signals intelligence and there
bunch of others but we invented Market
which was Market intelligence and uh um
published some articles which I can't
discuss they're they're so classified to
this day but uh there's there's a
classified peer review scarly journal
inside the CIA where you get to
contribute articles like this so I can't
show my friends but they're there um so
we invented this new field and then we
uh developed a working prototype uh we
got funding from um uh something called
inq what the heck is inq inel is an
in-house uh CIA Venture Capital firm uh
there came a time in the 90s and early
2000s when the CIA said okay in the 70s
you know early we had all the cool
inventions we had the spy cameras and
the Spy pens and listing devices and all
that stuff you seen in the old James
Bond movies but uh but by the 90s that
was all happening in Silicon Valley you
know the the division of Science and
Technology the SEC still did some cool
or sorry the CIA still did a lot of cool
stuff but they they were having trouble
keeping up with the Silicon Val with
silicon valy so they said okay if you
can't beat them join them let's start a
private Equity Firm or Venture Capital
firm go out find the coolest stuff
invest in it get you know exclusive
rights or licenses or whatever if we can
and so that oh the by the way inq tell
so Intel intelligence that's easy but
the Q was ATT tribute to uh Q who was
the character in the James Bond movie
who he was the armorer he gave Bond the
asem Martin and the the the briefcase
and for Ru love and all that so we got
the money uh we built the thing we
promised them a go-kart we said for this
amount of money we'll build you go-kart
if you want a Rolls-Royce that's going
to be more expensive turns out our
go-kart ran like a Rolls-Royce it was
amazingly successful and we were finding
insider trading all the time now most of
it were just criminals you know SLE bags
on Wall Street it wasn't terrorist
related but we did have some success uh
we got a bright red on American Airlines
in August uh 2006 um and this was uh 3
days before the takedown of the liquid
bomb plot this was the one where there
this is why you can't take a bottle of
water on an airplane to this day because
the terrorists were going to take the
precursor chemicals in different bottles
and then mix them on the plane blow up
the plane that 10 flights targeted going
to kill 3,000
Americans 3 days before that was taken
down we got a bright red on America we
escalated it it would kind of went
through the intelligence Community but
what uh we didn't we didn't bust the
plot but we saw the plot in motion
before it happened before MI5 in New
Scotland Yard I I was actually working
at 2:00 in the morning uh watching CNN
uh I was working with CNN with the sound
off and all of a sudden I look at the
screen and I see all these you know uh
London cops and and and uh Scotland Yard
like breaking down all these doors all
over London well it turns out they were
was live coverage of busting up this
plot and uh I called my partner and said
well the machine works because we saw
that three days in advance so um
uh that was uh did that for a long time
uh and then at some point uh I guess I
was doing a radio interview on NPR and
uh this person you know NPR people are
funny they just listen they love NPR you
know they listen to it all the time so
uh got um I was in my car and I got a
phone call this nice lady she introduced
herself and she said um I'm a literary
agent I heard you on NPR would you like
to write a book and you know you the
number of authors you meet who have been
like slaving away at manuscripts and
submitting them to Publishers and
getting rejected and all that stuff and
here or she's opening the door and I
learn later that the publishing industry
is uh it's not supply driven it's demand
driven they have to kind of want your
book but uh I said yeah let's talk we
met for lunch hit it off I worked up and
outline it took a while to come together
but that was uh we met with Publishers
and we found a a great publisher a
penguin random house I was Penguin at
the time but they merched random house
since then so uh wrote a book uh was my
first book it was a bestseller uh was
currency Wars um you know write book at
the right time came out in
2011 um I love it when reporters today
say uh they'll see some headline oh this
a currency war I said no it's the same
currency War we've had since 2010 it's
just how currency Wars roll they last
for 15 or 20 years we're not in them all
the time but when we are they can last
for 15 or 20 years so that book uh it's
still still in print still selling well
uh and uh it's still very fresh it's
very difficult in economics most
economists don't write books they write
articles some do but most of them just
write you know um academic articles uh
but the hard part is writing an
economics book that's not a textbook and
I had no interest in writing a textbook
something for everyday readers that's
still fresh 5 years later 10 years later
that's hard to do because you get caught
up in the the debate of the day as it
were uh and uh but you want to do
something big you deal with what's
happening but you want to do something
bigger than that theoretically so it has
some shelf life and uh so that led to a
total of five books at this point uh so
I guess that makes you an establish
author they've all been either New York
Times or Wall Street Journal bestsellers
they're all still in print they have a
big following I do a lot of public
speaking and Consulting and I draw on my
legal background and my intelligence
background and my Capital markets
background to synthesize what's going on
in markets and as I say this um LED not
just to to writing books but newsletters
uh which I do on a regular basis and
public speaking and have some Consulting
clients so here I am I don't know how
you describe that career path going from
uh banking to Investment Banking to
hedge funds to a stock exchange to the
CIA to being an author but uh to me it's
it's life it's one is kind of a threat
bread that runs uh runs through it all
so I have had a fascinating life and
people who know me would agree I've had
a fascinating life and you just made it
look really ordinary that the uh
stunning so a couple of things I I want
to um start with the end the perspective
that you um had access to you know
through your career is a a rare view
it's a rare perch to be able to have
seen from the inside all the things that
you've
seen
what starting with you know right now
today based on your perspective what are
you telling people what are you you know
what's coming next what's really
happening now and how can someone
watching this utilize that based
on your unique perspective sure um there
are a couple big themes and I'll try to
keep them concise but then we can we
expand if you like um the biggest thing
going on in the world but it's it's slow
motion so it's not I I'll describe it
for you but don't think that the you
know the world's going to come to an end
tomorrow uh it's not at least I don't
expect it you know it's funny when
you're in my position people uh you know
because I'm I've got the books and I'm
active on Twitter and I'm on TV and I'm
kind of out there a lot but people love
to put words in your mouth and you know
they say well Jim rard says that you
know world's coming to an end so
everything buy gold well I've never said
any of those things I don't believe any
of those things I don't believe the
world's coming to an end we may go
through financial crashes and panics and
you come out the other side and the
world is different yeah that could
happen um I don't say sell everything I
say uh uh and buy gold I say buy some
gold have a slice but there's plenty of
room for diversification in your
portfolio uh but the biggest thing going
on right now is uh is debt and in
particular you know is debt a good thing
or a bad thing well it depends what you
do with the money if you borrow money
and you can invest it at a higher return
create productivity make your money back
and pay back the debt that's just fine
manage it well and invest it well and
there's nothing wrong with debt most of
the so-called money supply isn't money
it's credit um and uh but on the other
hand if you borrow the money to pay your
bills don't have any more money coming
in don't know how you're going to pay
them next month and you're going to have
to borrow more you're probably heading
for bankruptcy so debt is not good or
bad it it can be either depending on how
you use it and how you manage it and is
your debt burden sustainable so how does
this apply to countries and again going
back to my uh experience in the 80s with
with the Government Bond Market which
I've stayed current with well you uh and
I have a a chapter on this in my new
book aftermath is chapter 2 a lot of
people kind of Imagine well you know
George Washington got sworn in in uh you
know 1789 and he borrowed some money and
it kept going up and up and up and up
and here we are with President Trump and
we got $22 trillion worth of debt uh but
almost as if it the national jti just
went up the whole time that is not what
happened first of all Washington had
national debt before we had a nation
before he was sworn in because they had
Revolutionary War debt uh that was that
was unpaid when George Washington became
president and so he says what should we
do with this debt and of course the
Congress at the time said well just
don't pay it you know it's the American
way just don't pay it uh and was
Alexander Hamilton who turned to
Washington and said no what we do is we
borrow more we use that money to pay off
the old debt now we've established our
credit we can borrow more to pay off the
new debt and just keep going and that
was the invention of the Government Bond
Market it's been going strong for 230
years so Hilton understood that credit
could be a good thing again always
provided you put it to good use um and
in fact uh and the way to think about
debt national debt is the debt to GDP
ratios so GDP gross domestic product
that's the the the value of all goods
and services how big is the economy in
other words so knows what's the debt
relative to the economy and just to
simplify that um I tell people well if
you have a MasterCard and you have um
$25,000 of of debt and you've used up
your line of credit uh are you in
trouble or not well if you make
$220,000 as a barista nothing wrong with
being a barista and you got a $25,000
balance on your credit card you're
probably heading for bankruptcy but if
you make 200,000 a year you can probably
just write a check and pay the whole
thing off so you can only evaluate the
debt relative to the income to support
it so the same thing what's the national
debt relative to GDP relative to the
size of the economy and when you look at
that number what you find is that it
went up and down and up and down and up
and down it was a sine wave uh and
actually in 1837 when Andrew Jackson
left office the national debt was Zero
he was the only president to completely
pay off the national debt he also
abolished the central bank so Jackson's
Legacy was no debt no Central Bank
pretty good Legacy if you ask me we
didn't have a central bank again until
1913 uh believe it or not so um but it
went up or down so what was what was the
driver behind that well why did it go up
and why did it go down and why was it
being managed that way and the answer
was very clear which is it went up in
times of War so you know the War of 1812
the Mexican-American War 1848 obviously
the Civil War Spanish American War World
War I World War II the debt went up
because it's either existential or you
you got to win the war and you got to
pay for it but in times of Peace it went
down again so in the late 19th century
between the Civil War and the uh Spanish
American War the debt went down uh
between uh the War of 1812 and the Civil
War or actually the Mexican American War
1848 the debt went down so it went up in
times of war and down in times of peace
and this was a bipartisan thing it was
not political it was considered prudent
Republicans and Democrats or you know
Federalist and wigs whoever it was
agreed on this this was and it all goes
back to the idea of dry powder in other
words you never know when there's going
to be another War you never know when
you're going to have to borrow so it's
prudent to reduce your borrowing when
you can so that you can increase it when
you must this pattern persisted all the
way through World War II and at the end
of World War II the debt to GDP ratio
was about
120% the highest in US history but we
won we won we and our Allies won the war
so we kind of got it was horrific but we
kind of got something for the money and
what was interesting is what came next
from uh
1946 to
1980 uh so that's a 34e period um the
debt to GDP ratio was reduced from
120% to 30% and that was Harry Truman
Dwight Eisenhower John Kennedy Lyndon
Johnson Richard Nixon Gerald Ford and
Jimmy Carter you had Republic an and
Democrats liberals and conservatives
persistently persistently reducing the
debt to GDP ratio because they knew that
had to be done and when Ronald Reagan
was sworn in in January uh 1981 the debt
to GDP ratio was 30% by the way just put
those numbers in context 30% is very
manageable very sustainable nobody
thinks a 30% debt to GDP ratio um is a
problem and uh but that was a huge
accomplishment it took the fed the
treasury both political parties National
consens is a lot of leadership to get
there but we did it now Reagan who has
his reputation as a physical
conservative no he was the last of The
Big Spenders he took the death to GDP
ratio from 30 to 50 now 50 is not out of
control but that's a 60% increase in the
debt to GDP ratio but he won the Cold
War now I say he won the Cold War uh
again that was every president from
Truman to George HW Bush and the
American people won the Cold War but
rean crushed the Soviet Union with um
the Strategic Defense Initiative
so-called Star Wars 600 ship Navy uh and
a lot else so he spent the money but he
got something for the money which is we
crushed the Soviet Union I didn't
necessarily think I would see that in my
lifetime going back to the 60s and
70s but if you follow this pattern
what's supposed to happen next under
George HW Bush and Bill Clinton they're
supposed to take it back down again
maybe to the 30% level to their credit
they held constant uh through uh the
late 80s and all the 1990s up until 2000
that ratio uh remained around 55 60% it
fluctuate a little bit and down and up
it didn't get worse but it didn't get a
lot better um and so when did it go off
the rails and since 2000 we've gone off
the rails so Bill Clinton left office we
had $5 trillion of national
debt after George W Bush George W bush
doubled it to 10 trillion
Obama doubled it again to 20 trillion
from a higher level so if you look at
the chart I just described the hockey
stick where that where that ratio goes
straight up was under the Obama
Administration where growth was weak he
inherited this financial crisis from
from George Bush and the borrowing was
huge the famous
$830 billion stimulus plan from Larry
Summers which didn't stimulate anything
but they borrow the money anyway so um
and then when Trump comes in now the
ratio is 105% and Trump has thrown a
couple trillion more of debt on top of
that now it's up to 106% and heading
higher so it was really the tail end of
George W bush all the Obama
Administration and the beginning of the
Trump Administration where this pattern
I describe was broken uh we we had the
Iraq War in
in3 but um there were no major wars
during the Obama Administration none so
far during the Trump Administration it's
a period when based on historic
precedent they should have got that
ratio backed down to at least 50 maybe
lower and they didn't they doubled it to
well over 100% why is that important why
is that significant well there's a huge
body first of all the the the historic
pattern is now off the rail so 230 years
of pretty good debt management out the
window we're just out of control and
unlike World War II we didn't win
anything you know we took the ratio up
but what did we get for the money hard
to say the weakest expansion in US
history is what we
got but uh but beyond that uh you know
with these we know we're back to the age
of of trillion dollar deficit there's a
large body of research very convincing
very uh rigorous in my view conducted by
uh Carmen Reinhardt and Ken rogoff
they're they're both at Harvard Carmen
used to be at the University of uh
Maryland but they're both at Harvard now
and and their Associates and other other
researchers that shows that 90% is a Red
Zone so I said 0 to 30 no problem it's
manageable 30 to 60 sustainable over 60
you got a problem but you know show me
you it's not too late you can get it
back down but once you're over 90 um a
couple things happen you're through
you're through the Looking Glass now uh
you're not getting any growth for the
debt so the the keian theory is uh yeah
Minal liquidity trap nobody wants to
borrow or spend so the government needs
to step in create what they call
aggregate demand so the government
borrows a dollar spends a dollar and you
get a120 of growth um well that sounds
pretty good you know spend a dollar and
got a dollar2 of growth that's the you
know the dollar the government spends
the recipient he spends it and then she
spends it and you get velocity and you
get more than you borrow it in effect
keen's called that as general theory
it's really more of a special theory
that actually does work for a short
period of time in certain conditions
when you're in a recession or a
depression or you're just coming out of
one there's slack in the labor market
unused industrial capacity plenty of
borrowing power low interest rates good
credit there's a set of conditions where
that can be true for a period of time
and you can break out of the liquidity
trap but only in those conditions but we
don't have any of those conditions today
we have massive debts we um uh you know
we don't we're not coming out of a
recession we're in the 11th year of an
expansion uh unemployment is at a
50-year low Etc all the conditions that
ke's Envision don't apply
uh and when you get and what Ryan Hart
and rogoff shows once you get past 90%
you don't get the bank for the buck in
fact you borrow a dollar spend a dollar
and you get maybe 90 cents of growth in
other words your debts going up faster
than GDP and what does that mean that
means that ratio is going up faster and
and the American people you know I say
uh uh you know when it comes to your own
money everyone has a PHD uh you know
don't sell the American people sht even
if you uh you know uh have minimal
economic training uh which is true of
most people um they look at that and
they go you know I may not be an expert
there's something not right about this
I'm concerned about the debt I'm
concerned about weak growth uh maybe
I'll save more personally just because
I'm not sure the government's doing
enough uh maybe I'll buy some gold or
land or hard assets because I'm worried
that they're going to inflate their way
out of it I don't know exactly what's
going to happen next but it's going to
be a bad outcome and I'm going to
prepare for that personally that's the
most we're in right now we we as you say
11 years we're in the 11th year of an
expansion sounds good it's the weakest
expansion in US history uh the average
growth rate for the last uh again over
10 years now in the 11th year is uh
about
2.1% historically at least since the
1980s expansions have grown about 3.2%
and if you go back to the end of World
War II it's even stronger than that so
this gap between you know say 3.2% uh
historic Trend growth and
2.1% actual growth that Gap it's a wedge
it keeps getting wider and that Gap is
lost wealth that's money that the
economy could have made wealth that
could have been created that wasn't
created because we can't get back to
Trend growth and that number today is
about $5 trillion can you imagine
someone walking into the Oval Office
handing the president a check for5
trillion and say here Mr President spend
it any way you like you know you want
defense cut taxes benefits uh whatever
you want to do do well that's how much
wealth that America has left on the
table by its failure to get back to
Trend growth and you say well why can't
we get back there and people like Larry
Summers throw up the hand and go secular
stagnation well that's a description
it's not it's not an explanation um but
the better explanation in my view one
that holds up empirically is the one
that Reinhardt and rogov gave which is
no when when you get the debt up that
high you get weaker growth you can't
borrow and spend your way out of it
although we're trying to but this is the
end this is impotent fiscal policy what
what do you do in fiscal policy doesn't
work and that over 90% at to GDP it
doesn't work it give you another whole
explanation why monetary policy doesn't
work either but basically the twin
engines the twin Pistons of monetary
policy and fiscal policy have both
failed uh monetary policy hit the wall
in December 2018 When J pal threw in the
tow on rate increases and balance sheet
reductions what's he doing now what's
the FED doing now rate cuts and balance
sheet increases we're back to qe4 and
rates are heading back to zero uh pal
won't say that but I'll say it because
I've met with Central Bankers this is
what they say behind closed doors so um
so they failed to normalize interest
rate the FED failed to normalize
interest rates failed to normalize the
balance sheet Congress failed to control
the debt GDP ratio and now our two
Pistons are gummed up monetary policy
doesn't work uh because they can't get
to where they want to be without causing
the recession they're preparing to
prevent and fiscal policy doesn't work
because the debt level is too high and
people don't have confidence in it and
they're not willing to borrow lend and
spend so we're we're Japan the US is
Japan that's the problem so it's funny
all of this is occurring and for people
like
me we only have a vague sense of it but
we have a sense of it it is there's you
know where you can look at it and see
what's happening I think the whole
country can feel that it's happen
without being able to point a finger at
it and say okay this is specific I think
that's exactly right people's people
again they may not have the PHD but they
have the intuition they know something's
not right the as you describe it and and
go through history and then where it's
almost like who sits in the white house
or who's controlling Congress doesn't
matter and
does do you see in in this upcoming
election do you see does it matter who
sits in that seat it matters a lot now
I'll I'll grant that uh different
presidents of different priorities and
FDR you know in the
1930s uh he was fighting two Wars we had
a you know a depression so it was kind
of a war on poverty war on depression
war on deflation then he ended up with a
shooting War World War II so he had he
had a full plate if you will so I don't
fault FDR for doing what he did on the
debt he almost had to do that but he was
starting at a time when we had that
capacity what if you were president and
you were confronted with FDR's dilemma
starting with 106% debt to GDP ratio
this is my point you bring it down so
that you can take it up when you need to
and FDR had that capacity but if
something like the Great Depression came
along tomorrow um we're we're already at
the limit now does it matter who becomes
president the answer is yes because uh
there's a new Theory out there there and
this is kind of an extension to what we
just discussed um it's people don't
understand it even so I've seen experts
get it wrong uh it's called modern
monetary Theory or mmt uh the first
thing you need to know it's not modern
the precursor goes back to
1905 uh a German Economist named gorg
knop who wrote uh the theory of State
money I I actually have a first edition
of the book in German from 1905 it's
given to me as a gift um but uh so it's
around it's not really Theory because
you can't falsify it but they call it
modern monetary Theory now what does it
say it says that um you can borrow and
spend as much as you want and just to
kind of go to the politics so uh what
are we hearing from the Democrats well
uh Green New Deal Medicare for all um
daycare for all free tuition uh you know
Etc this this whole list of programs and
there used to be a very simple way to
shut down that debate which is ah it's
interesting but we can't afford it uh
and based on what I just said about the
debt to GDP ratio I think that's right
we can't afford it but they have a new
and they used to go yeah you're right
and it'd go away um now they have a new
answer which is yes we can yes we can
afford because all that we have to do is
just the treasury will just borrow the
money and spend it spend it on the new
green deal spend it on Medicare for all
whatever it is and if the bond market
boxs in any way at the issuance of all
that new debt call the fed and have the
FED buy it by printing money and put it
on their balance sheet and wait 20 years
and collect the money at maturity what's
the
problem well what is the problem there
are a lot of problems but when you put
it that way it's like yeah well what's
the problem why can't we do that and um
the thought leader on this uh the big
brain is a lady named Stephanie Kelton
she's a uh professor of Economics at the
State University of New York in
Stonybrook she also happens to be the
chief economic adviser to the Bernie
Sanders 2020 campaign so so when you see
and I won't pick on Sanders but when you
see Sanders Elizabeth Warren I mean Joe
Biden doesn't really know he's doing but
these others coming out with all these
programs and um you know and then the
reporters uh you know say well how you
going to pay for it you know and they've
had to kind of shuck and drive their way
through uh well we're we're we're going
to tax billionaires you know we're not
going to tax you we're just going to tax
billionaires and all this and then
people crunch the numbers say oh no that
that gets you 10 billion you need 90
billion for this you know what they are
not saying uh what they won't say is
that they see no impediment to borrowing
the money because in fact the treasury
can borrow as much money as as it can
there there's a debt ceiling but the
Congress has always extended it the FED
there's no legal limit on what they can
print they used to be there used to be
as late as
1968 there there was a gold to money
ratio um I know Roosevelt endered ended
the domestic gold standard in the 1930s
and Nixon end ended the international
standard 1971 but but um through from
19133 to 1968 the FED could not expand
the money supply Beyond a certain
multiple of the amount of physical gold
that was held in this case at the
treasury the Congress got rid of that in
68 to help pay for the Vietnam War so um
and and the Great Society so now there
really is no limit and you know and and
I don't want to put words in her mouth I
met Stephanie Kelton very nice lady she
would she and other mmt Advocates would
say well look bernachi proved our point
because Ben Baki between 2008 and 2014
expanded the fed's balance sheet from
$800 billion to $4.5 trillion uh he more
than tripled it uh and uh he quadrupled
it and uh uh he said well that Pro and
nothing bad happened right we didn't
have you we got out of the recession we
didn't have a depression that's
debatable but we talk about that later
uh we didn't have the all these people
oh you print that much money you're
going to get inflation no actually
inflation has nothing to do with money
printing has has to do with psychology
that's a separate subject but um nothing
bad happened we just kept growing uh and
what they say is like you you did that
to prop up jery damond's bonus we want
to do it for other reasons you know the
green new deal but you proved it can be
done with no bad consequences so don't
tell us we can't do it number one number
two look at Japan what's Japan's uh debt
to GDP ratio it's about
250% it's more than double the United
States So when you say where's the 100
trillion going to come from that
probably be enough to pay for most of
these programs 100 trillion um say just
borrow and spend it and uh if the US
debt the GDP ratio goes from 106% to
215% or you know whatever whatever the
number might be um what's the big deal
the Japanese are already there you know
you go to ginso the lights are on the
restaurants are open uh it's not the end
of the world over there so this is uh
first of all they're not being the
academics are being transparent they
publish papers you can go read them
they're really painful to read I I have
read them all and I have a chapter 5 of
my new book aftermath covers this uh but
I I've delved into it just because I
think it's important politically to
understand it even though I think there
are a lot of problems with it but uh so
they're out there but the politicians
who are listening to the people I'm
describing won't say it because they
know it scares the American people but
it's why they're being very bold uh and
very willing to advance all these
programs because they're not assuming
that they're going to tax the money they
raise the money by taxes they're
assuming they can just borrow and spend
it and and if you think that's true then
you actually
can from from what you're saying and the
the question that comes up for me is is
like well you're right they're right
Japan's still there people are still
able to go eat and drive cars so what
you know where's the the downside of
this well let me uh let me kind of
explain what my friend Stephanie Kelton
and her uh colleagues and the
politicians who listen to them are
missing which is um first of all there's
some major differences between Japan and
the United States they're both developed
economies they both have large debt
loads but the Japanese owe the money to
themselves the Japanese people uh the
government borrows the money runs
deficits but most of the debt is sold to
the Japanese people so I compare the
Japanese to you know 14 people in a
Lifeboat uh with limited Provisions but
the one thing you don't want to do in a
Lifeboat is Rock the Boat uh you don't
want to cause a panic or you don't want
to A dissension and as long as they owe
the money to themselves and as long as
they're willing to hold the government
debt as a you know Social Security
equivalent or you know store of wealth
and they can keep rolling it over manage
it in some way that sort of works two
big differences with the United States
number one we're much more heter genius
and the Japanese I mean Japanese are
just they're all one strongly bound
culture they don't don't allow
immigration in the United States they
don't have anywhere near uh the
diversity the cultural political
economic diversity that the United
States has number one number two we're
the dollar so in a way we're propping up
the whole world part of the reason
people still have confidence in the Yen
and the Japanese government bond market
is because they're like well the US
Government Bond Market is supporting
this whole thing and the US dollar is
supporting the whole thing we're the
foundation what happens if you undermine
confidence in the US dollar the whole
pyramid collapses so the US has a
special role it is the leading Global
Reserve currency uh you know country
reserves it's like your savings account
so if you make $100,000 and you spend
$80,000 and expenses and taxes and you
got $20,000 left over you put in the
bank or invest in the stock market
that's your reserve that's your your net
of your income and your spending well
it's no different with countries they um
have a certain amount of uh exports
where they make money and they have have
a certain amount of imports where they
spend money and if you have a trade
surplus that that goes into your reserve
position well glob this is true of all
the countries in the world global
reserves 60% of them are denominated in
US Dollars and I'm talking China Taiwan
Japan South Korea Germany all these
countries that have big surpluses they
invest in US Dollars number one about
80% of Global Payments are in US Dollars
and I'm including uh Capital markets
transactions um but the price of oil is
about 100% denominating US dollars so
we're not just another currency we're
not just a currency you get when you
come to see the Empire State Building we
are the foundation of the whole global
system so if you undermine confidence in
the dollar the ramifications go Way
Beyond the United States and about um it
varies but about 17 18% of the US
national debt is held by foreigners uh
it's held outside the United States so
our national debt is about $22 trillion
so imagine uh uh you know about uh five
trillion of that uh held by who China
Japan Taiwan South Korea Germany the
countries I mentioned some of them are
allies but some of them are identified
as enemies right now when particularly
including China I'm not saying China's
going to wake up and dump their
treasuries the president could stop that
with one phone call what I'm saying is
at the margin if they buy less reduce
their position shorten the maturities
that puts pressure on the US Government
Bond Market in in ways that we don't see
in Japan so so we're we're not we're
Japan in terms of growth we're Japan in
terms of debt being a headwind of growth
but we're not Japan in terms of the role
of the currency we're much more the
foundation of the whole system number
one number two
um what the modern monetary theorists
fail to take into account is the
psychological aspect of confidence in
the US dollar so you say and I i' I've
had these debates you know you say to my
monetary theorist well what what's your
what's behind your assumption that the
treasury can borrow as much as they want
spend as much as they want the FED can
just monetize it and it's all good
because that is what they say um and
they say well uh it has to do with the
tax system so the US government collects
taxes in dollars if I want to give the
US government you know can tuna fish to
pay my taxes they say no thank you give
me dollars so therefore Americans are
trapped into a dollar system we have to
earn and save dollars whether we like it
or not because we have to pay our taxes
um and when I've debated this I said
well you know I'm not advocating this
what happens if you don't pay your taxes
uh well I I know the answer they the IRS
will send you a letter saying you know
you didn't pay your taxes and what
happens if you throw the letter in the
trash well they'll send you a demand
notice they'll um and then you throw
that in the trash well they'll start the
enforcement mechanism they'll freeze
your bank account you know put a lean on
your house and what happens if you still
don't pay your taxes well some guy with
a badge and a gun will show up at your
door and take you to jail that's what
happens to people who don't pay their
taxes so I say your theory of confidence
in the US dollar comes from the barrel
of a gun this is a Neo fascist system
and not surprising that you know Germany
was behind the whole thing because this
kind of played out right through to uh
to the National Socialist Party in in
the 1930s uh but um that's that's a heck
of a way to get confidence and my point
is you can't actually enforce it how
much taxes Mark Zuckerberg paid on
hundred billion dollar of wealth not
very much some yeah but he owns the
stock if he doesn't sell the stock he
doesn't owe any taxes if he gives a
stock to a foundation uh the foundation
itself pays no taxes at all so rich
people don't pay taxes poor people don't
pay taxes because they don't make enough
money the middle class pays all the
taxes so this your whole modern monetary
theory is a Neo fascist gun to the head
of the middle class in the United States
you think you've got you've taken the
prisoner and they got to keep making
dollars because they got to pay those
taxes so that's the first thing that's
kind of very unpower about the whole
thing they don't like to talk about that
the second thing is uh okay got to pay
my taxes but I have something left over
I don't have to hold US dollars I don't
have to hold bank accounts I don't have
to put in the stock market I can buy
gold land silver real estate hard assets
natural resources I can buy a new car in
other words there are a lot of things
that people can do to get out of the US
dollar system by converting their dollar
assets into other things and once that
happens once that that gains momentum
now uh interest rates go up you know
inflation can take off uh the system can
come spiraling down and mmt answer is
well we'll just ra we can deal with
inflation by raising taxes oh really
you've got inflation out of control your
economy is weak and you're solutions to
raise taxes that doesn't work so what
they're ignoring uh the they're again
modern monetary theory was called the
state theory of money when you hear the
word State you know chill should go up
your spine uh about what's behind it and
what's behind it is violence and um so
so the problem really is that you're
treating the American people like
they're on a plantation and they they
got to keep working for you and they
can't get off and that's not true they
they can get off and there are a lot of
ways to do it uh and there's an
invisible confidence boundary why do you
think the FED took quantitative easing
money printing to 4 and a half trillion
and then try to get it back down again
they did they got it down to like 3.8
trillion it's going up again today by
the way but they got to a ceiling and
that why do they think they did that
because they know they won't put it
quite the way I'm putting it but they
know at some level trillion 5 half
trillion 6 trillion there's an invisible
confidence boundary where again the
American people look at it and they go
you know what I'm not the chairman of
the FED I don't have a PhD but I don't
like what I see get me out of the dollar
and when that happens the whole thing
can collapse just like that this is
absolutely fascinating um I I look
forward to uh going back and reading
five books and uh and picking up this
conversation again thank you great to
have you thanks a
lot
[Music]
okay time for a quick quiz what's the
best performing asset of the last 20
years it's not stocks or bonds and it's
not cryptocurrencies or real estate 90
years ago this asset was worth $20 today
it's worth many many times more than $20
inflation adjusted yes of course I'm
still talking about gold in times of the
falling dollar it's the one asset you
want to own here's author Adam barata
with the
answer Adam thanks for inviting us into
your office and and spending some time I
know this is going to be a hell of a
conversation yeah I'm excited about it
yeah so uh you and I have met this first
time I'm meeting you face to face but we
we have spoken on the phone before and
uh you have an enthusiasm around what
you do here that is contagious and I
think you have really rational arguments
for it but uh what's your background how
did you get to be doing what you're
doing today well uh I was we're in
Hollywood and I uh came out to LA um
didn't do my jdmba uh and whing in pen
like my father wanted me to uh came out
here to be an actor get in the movie
business uh that led to uh a a decade of
doing uh bit parts and little things mhm
uh led to writing and then directing and
then I got into producing
mhm uh
realized I was pretty good at the
producing part uh ultimately I think
producers uh are great salesmen MH
that's what we do is we're selling you
know the the studio selling uh the the
the talent selling the key people MH and
uh I had I I pretty good salesman and
the best salesman fall in love with
their product and so yeah um all of that
uh was my background uh that went
sideways um and I was kind of uh at 43
years old trying to figure out what I
was going to do with my life so you had
no nothing in this world of gold before
year 43 no 43 years old um been evicted
from my house I am my car has been
repossessed uh project that I have with
uh uh major players Stanley Comcast the
National Hockey League goes
sideways um and I needed a job so a
friend of mine was selling gold I had no
idea what gold was really other than it
was
shiny and uh on the first day I was
given a one-page script and said uh now
go
sell uh and that's really when this
journey started um I uh had no idea what
I was doing and I wanted to make sure if
I was going to recommend something to
people that I really had a reason to
recommend it and then the more I got
into this story The more passionate I
became because I believed it's a story
that uh most people don't know uh and
that uh affected everyone and that uh
that passion led
to uh understanding how the industry
works you say industry yeah the go the
the precious metals
industry um and how other companies were
doing it and there was a there's a lot
of fear
based uh you know um working on the gold
is a is seen as a um something you want
to own when the World falls apart right
it's like a prepper commodity it is and
that's how that's how it was how it's
been marketed as well um it's you know
if you if you like gold you must be
crazy because Gold's for crazy people
right and uh the more I understood what
drives markets
uh the why behind why things are the way
they are uh the more I started to
realize that the story is much bigger uh
that gold isn't a bearish asset uh gold
uh actually is probably the best
performing asset certainly of the last
20 years MH and then the why behind that
so uh a long answer to your short
question is um I found a story that I
become incredibly passionate about and
for the last uh five years I've been
trying to tell that story to as many
people as I can so you talk about the
story so what is the story of gold so if
I say okay so what is the story of gold
how you know how would you tell it um I
have a site that has over 20 hours of
content trying to tell this story see
gold is not as an asset is a chameleon
it works in different ways at different
times uh but ultimately um you know the
story of gold is really the story of
currencies and and the
dollar uh and the easiest way to tell
that story is that uh the dollar at one
time was backed by gold right the
so-called gold standard yes the gold
standard um 90 years ago a 1 o gold coin
um was a $20 bill they were
interchangeable right okay uh we
couldn't print any money without
reserves of gold behind it mhm
uh in fact uh on every paper bill on the
back it says in God we trust and at one
time that made sense because gold is
from God uh and the dollar was backed by
gold so it was as good as gold and I
could remember when I was a little kid
the dollars could have like I think they
blue gold it was a gold certificate as
compared to something else there were
gold certificates that's exactly right
keep in mind you could go gold was
currency so you could walk into to a
tailor shop the the famous example uh 90
years ago with a $20 bill or a 1 o gold
coin and buy a top-of-the-line Man suit
mhm uh today you can walk into a tailor
shop and with a 1o gold coin buy a
top-of-the-line Man's suit $5,600 suit
right uh a $20 bill won't even buy you a
pocket square H uh and so so and this is
interesting so yeah let's like go
because this is what I think people
don't get is that if 90 years ago you
know let's say that somebody lived you
know for 90 years and you were uh a year
old yeah and you were given by one
relative a $20 bill and you given by
another relative an ounce of gold it
would been equivalent value correct and
if if you stored that or let's say you
gave it to your
grandchild uh and one grandchild got the
$20 bill one grandchild got the 1 ounce
of gold two very very different than
without question so is that like pretty
much the the story in in a in a nutshell
or it is in fact um the we don't need to
go back 90 years see this is the story I
became passionate about uh in the year
2000 it took 23 $20 bills to buy one
ounce of gold it was worth
$260 wow okay mhm uh today it takes 88
or you know whatever the the moving
price is where are we at today uh gold
yeah that's 1,600 so 80 uh uh $20 bills
today uh from what was 23 $20 bills just
20 years ago yeah uh and that's really
the the premise is um the first I I
wound up writing a book called gold is a
better way MH uh and the entire argument
started from and my passion started from
wait a second why does Wall Street tell
us that gold is a terrible asset to own
MH it's been branded for crazy people
something uh you know you only want when
the World falls apart so the question I
ask is has the world Fallen apart in the
last 20 years stock market was here 20
years ago gold was here 20 years ago the
Dow Jones was at 12,000 points in the
year 2000 it's a was it 24,000 yesterday
uh it's probably going to be below
20,000 tomorrow uh but the reality is
it's doubled in 20 years gold was $250
an ounce 20 years ago and it's over,
1500 it's uh you know up uh five times
six times yeah so it's interesting about
this and maybe we'll talk about you know
the manipulation of currency and and the
implications of all that because I think
that's a part of that story right that's
important but you know a friend of mine
who very prominent uh Wall Street Banker
uh you know worked at you know very high
level at JP Morgan you know uh he would
say you know he was poo poo go goes you
know why you why is gold better than
than cash you know he said you what are
you going do if there's a if there's a
big problem you're going to eat the gold
you can't eat it you can't do it it's
just you know it's a it's just something
that's a perception of value that has no
real application I said well it does
have actually some you know industrial
applications but beside that it is yeah
you a standard so so let's start with
what the gold standard was and what
happened when we went off of it yeah we
we absolutely can so uh the idea behind
the gold stand see for thousands of
years gold has been money MH
um an interesting side note on that the
mankind has grown at an average pace of
one and a half% per year historically
that's the population growth of man
interestingly enough um the gold
discoveries have grown at 1 and a half%
per yearh uh gold is an element it is
static uh it can't be created mankind
for thousands of years through Alchemy
has tried to create Gold by putting
other materials together right we've
been unable to so it's finite it's
finite uh and uh gold is from God it's a
it's a it's an element uh and for that
reason uh gold became a you know keep in
mind what happens in the expansion of
the of the world population you have uh
populations growing in different
countries um what might be important in
one country as a commodity that trades
uh may be less valuable somewhere else
but you need a standard that uh everyone
agrees has the same value gold MH became
that standard MH so gold you could
travel from country to Country and I
could exchange my gold for cotton or
wheat or corn or uh silk and uh there
was a uh whether you were working in you
know corn units or working in silk units
it had a a number in Gold that it was
worth and that then became how trade was
conducted so it's a reference point more
than that though because it was a
reference point that was finite it was a
reference point that had value because
of that finite
Supply um you know gold is kind of the
perfect uh currency because it's not
only finite uh it's malleable at a
certain temperature so it can turn into
coins or bars uh which also made it
appealing MH um and another reason is
that uh uh it's it's something you can't
create out of thin air MH uh the fact
that it's beautiful I'm sure it didn't
hurt either yeah so it became the
perfect currency MH um what's
interesting about the history of gold
and this is what I learned that got me
passionate about this story uh the Roman
Empire was the greatest Empire in the
world uh and what they you know silver
and gold were the current cury mhm and
over time what the rulers would do is uh
take away dute start deluding the gold
and silver uh so it wouldn't be 100%
pure would they take the Purity out and
at the end of the Roman Empire There Was
You know the silver in in a silver coin
had gone down to one/ 100th of the
original unit wow when they tried to pay
their soldiers their soldiers wouldn't
take the money and that's what really
caused the downfall of the Empire and
governments do this so that they can uh
continue to expand uh by diluting the
money supply and increasing the supply
of money so there's there's actually a a
precedent historically for what happens
when you start to dilute currency or
devalue a currency yeah in fact um
there's a law called gresham's law MH
which is the uh bad money chases out the
good mhm um and Gresham explained this
to I think it was King uh Henry iith uh
and explained the law and he said listen
here's the deal um the soldiers in Rome
would hold on to the valuable gold that
had the most gold and silver in it and
pay their taxes with the deluded metal
MH um and the gold the the good money
chases out the bad has historically been
what governments what what happens and
we're at that exact same moment in
history again right now
uh with what we're doing with the
massive money Printing and debt and
deficits that the world is in so in the
United States our monetary system was
pegged to a gold standard until Nixon's
presidency so what how was that an was
that an inflection point first of all do
you think and if so how so uh see this
is why the story takes so long to to
talk about it's actually the subject of
my next book called The Great
evaluation
um technically we were on a gold
standard until 19 1971 mhm what happened
in
1932 Franklin delar Roosevelt was
elected in the In the Heat of the Great
Depression MH uh keep in mind the
Roaring 20s had just ended a couple
years
earlier uh I I'll point out that
Franklin delanor Roosevelt today looks a
lot like Bernie Sanders looks a lot like
Elizabeth Warren his policies were
socialist policies um the New Deal
infrastructure spending but what
happened at that moment what got us to
that Roaring 20s and inflated
boom um was the Federal Reserve was
created in 1913 MH uh and as the Federal
Reserve their whole uh structure was to
extend and expand the money supply um
and by doing by expanding the money
supply uh prior to that gold and silver
were currencies there was no Central
Bank we we had local banks uh that
traded in gold and had their own little
uh units of paper that they would print
from the bank backed by gold right um
that became a difficult system to manage
uh for a for a central government so the
Federal Reserve was created as the
Central Bank of the country to um
control that um and ultimately JP Morgan
is the founder of the Federal Reserve
and his backstory is pretty interesting
um but
ultimately uh I think the easiest way to
explain it is on the on the face of
every paper currency or three words M
says Federal Reserve
Note uh that note uh is an obligation it
was an obligation that at one time was
backed by physical gold we couldn't
print any of those notes without gold
stored behind it um in 1932 In the Heat
of the Great
Depression uh Franklin Roosevelt BAS
basically took away the independence of
the Federal Reserve um the executive
branch and Congress took control of the
Federal Reserve they set monetary policy
uh and was able to set uh infrastructure
and spending bills uh that were fiscal
in nature and we're kind of right there
again right now and that's what this
election I think is really all about is
uh uh we're seeing what happened 90
years ago take place again right now so
we went off the gold standard yeah and
when we did that what started to happen
well what Roosevelt does is he uh makes
gold illegal for the citizens okay keep
in mind um the central banks hold
reserves of dollars when we trade and we
we we we import almost everything okay
dollars go out they sit in Reser in
central banks around the globe M uh and
those dollars were always exchangeable
for gold MH so while citizens couldn't
own gold since
1933 okay uh Roosevelt made owning
physical gold for the people illegal uh
central banks still traded in Gold so
this is interesting so it's not illegal
for citizens to own gold now correct
right so but Roosevelt said basically
you have to turn your gold in correct so
we what was that why would that be why
would why would the government say
everybody turn over your gold because we
had a debt crisis uh gold was considered
money MH uh the only thing to do in a
debt crisis is a devaluation of
currencies MH you can't devalue
something you don't control and this is
really how America became the most
powerful country in the world little
backstory a little background uh prior
to uh World War I the United States was
not a superpower we were a uh bunch of
farmer states on the on the East Coast
um and World War I pitted Europe against
each other MH uh the superpowers of
Europe through that war the United
States remained neutral we were selling
goods and products to both sides and as
our products went out gold poured in MH
so that by the end of World War I we had
uh most of the money all the money from
Europe had now come to the United
States in 1933 when Nixon closes I mean
when Roosevelt um makes gold illegal for
the citizens they had he didn't
basically take the gold away he you
could turn your gold in for paper notes
and so the currency was exchanged the
central bank now had all of the gold
when we are resetting the monetary
system in 1944 after World War II the
golden rule applies he who has the gold
makes the rules the United States had
all the gold we got to make the the
rules and the rules of the system were
the world will trade in dollars the
dollar will be backed by gold and that
was protection for every other country
around the world that we wouldn't just
devalue our dollars and at any time we
other countries could turn in their gold
their dollars or their gold for dollars
exchange it for dollars so if you had
reserves of dollars built up you could
ship them back to the United States and
take your gold mhm so that's what
happened in the 30s and why he did it
was once all of the gold had been turned
in he changed the price of gold
overnight by executive order from $20 to
$36 that
devaluation helped us get out of the
debt crisis see the only way when you
have a Deb isn't that an artificial way
I mean is that something that is
sustainable or I mean you can't just
it's like you know like a magic trick
you know we're going to make deck go
away just by The Stroke of a pen 1933
Roosevelt
uh makes gold illegal 1944 Breton Woods
1951 Breton Woods what uh Breton Woods
is the foundation of the new monetary
system I'm giving you how many times the
rules have changed okay
1951 the uh Federal Reserve gets control
back of uh monetary policy from the
treasury 1971 Nixon closes the gold
window 1985 the plaza Accord 1998
long-term Capital Management and uh the
uh uh Asian
contagion 2008 uh quantitative easing
and the printing of trillions of dollars
what most people don't know is that
every 15 20 years the rules have to
change and so an answer to your question
yes it's manipulation it's completely
manipulation and ultimately we're going
to need manipulation again because
that's where we're at once again at what
point and I guess there have been points
that there's got to be a reckoning right
Ian I mean you know you this is a a bit
of a Ponzi scheme isn't it so think
about it this way okay um in
1971 uh by that time gold was worth $42
per ounce okay keep in mind we had a
debt crisis then we had come out of
Vietnam okay we had been in War uh gold
was leaving our coffers we had a gold
crisis other countries were sending back
their dollars and taking gold out of our
coffers we had over 20,000 tons of
reserves of gold whittel down to 8,000
tons wow and we realized that if the
gold kept leaving the Golden Rule would
apply we wouldn't have the M most gold
and we wouldn't be the most powerful
country so gold is really F the
foundation of the entire monetary system
and in that process of the gold leaving
in this crisis Nixon directed his
treasury secretary to close the gold
window making uh the dollar a fiat
currency now if you were a Central Bank
of a foreign country and holding
reserves of dollars those dollars are no
longer backed by gold they're now backed
by one thing the full faith and credit
of the United States mhm so in 1971 the
dollar became a fiat currency uh over
the decade you'd see gold go from $42 an
ounce to 800 so in your view was was
Nixon right to do it to close the
window you know that's an interesting
question um I don't think about it in
those terms um you know we can go back
and look at quantitative easing and look
at these policies and see where they've
gotten us and what's
occurred um I think what the interesting
thing is if there was a mulligan or a
doover that every other country had to
go back to they might go back to
1971 because what it's allowed us to do
is to maintain our power on the world
stage because when you control the
world's currency you are the most
powerful right this is evident by the
fact that we have 5% of the world's
population and 25% of the world's wealth
and it's all because of the power of the
US dollar right so what I'm passionate
about talking about is why that power
exists the power struggle that's
happening right now the risk of losing
that status because the dollar is really
at risk of losing its Reserve currency
status and if we lose that uh America
will lose a tremendous amount of of our
power when did it change that we can
start owning gold again the citizens
well
um I believe they started making gold
coins again that the uh citizens could
buy in in uh
uh gold was uh something you could trade
uh but owning it physically through the
US Mint and minted coins was 1986 yeah
so uh in your view right now as far as
giving advice for people who want to
invest in gold uh you you believe in
physical gold not uh not other forms
well uh that's another great question um
I do I I am putting every penny I have
into physical gold uh it's what I'm
doing right now it's what I I'm planning
on doing for the foreseeable future
because I believe I know where the price
of gold is going and why MH um
ultimately I think you're going to see a
uh a dramatic increase in the price of
gold uh which is why I'm buying as much
of it as I can now you talked about debt
crisis from the past yeah um with the 20
plus trillion dollars of debt we have
now are we at a crisis level yeah so
that's why I'm so passionate about this
story Patrick um why is the market at
all-time highs why have these things
occurred wer is it because of growth
well here the here are the numbers in
the 80s and 90s our GDP average 4% a
year over the last 20 years has been
closer to 2% MH so when we hear this is
the best economy of all time uh that's
based on unemployment that's at alltime
lows and a stock market that's at all
time highs it's not built on growth it's
been built on debt and an easy way to
see that what does that mean when you
say built on debt what does that mean
I'm going I'm going to give you a visual
right now so uh in the year 2000 our GDP
was $10 trillion MH okay today it's $21
trillion so we've doubled the tree of
growth in 20 years in the year 2000 our
debt was 3.5 trillion MH it's now over
23 trillion it's gone up more than seven
times MH so when your debt exceeds your
growth by that dramatic level you have
you have an economy built on debt and
what um what what happened to get us to
this part of the story that's why I said
it's a big story in 2008 we had a
financial
crisis uh in a financial crisis the
Federal Reserve or in a recession the
Federal Reserve Cuts interest rates uh
500 basis points 5% mhm uh 1981 we had a
recession we cut interest rates from 18%
to 13% 1989 we had a recession we cut
interest rates from 10% to 4% so the
Playbook is uh is you know cut 5% or so
exactly right cut 5% in a uh in a
recession uh 2001 we have a recession we
cut interest rates from 6 and a/ qu% to
1 and a qu%
it created the housing boom mhm in 2008
we have a recession we cut interest
rates from 5% to zero but that wasn't
enough because cutting rates to zero
didn't restart the
economy uh we had to print four trillion
dollars basically of new money so we
added four trillion to the balance sheet
uh and the economy rlated so basically
so to get a visual on this $4 trillion
is printed you know created out of thin
air and and I think it's probably not
literally necessarily printed but it's
it it's created and put into where the
the central banks and the central banks
distribute it yeah exactly right so um
it it sounds complicated because it's a
bond buying program uh but it's
literally like taking money from your
left pocket and putting it in your right
pocket and counting it as new money okay
the uh Federal Reserve buys bonds from
the treasury mhm and then deposits the
cash for the purchases of those bonds
into the treasury's coffers the treasury
distributes that cash to the banks and
the banks are meant to go lend it and
this is why the stock market Rose 4X
over the last decade so because a lot of
this lending is I guess I guess it puts
it into all parts of the economy right
but then that creates you know uh
consumerism you know businesses you
people come and buy you know uh because
this money is available to be utilized
but it's not earned in value it's just
created out of nothing well let me
explain it a different way let me
explain a different way um the it's
where the money flows that matters the
most who has access to the money see in
in the early 2000s when we lowered
interest rates it was home buyers that
were had access to refinance their homes
right and as they refinance their homes
on cheaper credit okay uh they then
could take the cash out of their home
and use their homes like ATM machines
right of course what then happened was
uh the banks got greedy started lending
to people that uh really shouldn't have
the loans subprime mortgages and rather
than carry that risk on their own books
they packaged them and sold them as as
collateralized debt obligations to
investors MH saying that they were safe
MH the reality is they knew it was a
bunch of junk uh but they were making
fees selling it and they're getting the
risk off their books MH so uh naturally
when interest rates rise it collapses
the system and that's what happened the
uh housing bubble
collapsed uh you know and now think
about it from the retail side um it's
interesting because my maid had owned
three homes during this time yeah you
literally could go into a bank sign a
piece of paper and they would give you a
loan to go buy your home now think about
what that does to home prices yeah okay
so if you your neighbor and your other
neighbor all have access to a credit
line of $250,000 to go buy a home and a
home goes on the market for
189,000 well you can say well I can I
give you 195 I'll give you 200 I
remember the bidding worse and that's
what gets the the uh the valuations
overinflated yeah so you have
overinflated valuations built on bad
credit and when uh the reality of
valuations comes down or interest r
rates rise the bubble pops mhm and it's
a great way to explain what happened
over the last decade um CEOs let's let's
pretend we're a CEO it's
2009 uh the market has
collapsed uh you have now been given
here's free
money cost you nothing interest rates
are zero well as a CEO I have to say do
I really want to borrow because what am
I going to do with the money right I
guess I could go build new factories
spend more money on marketing and hope
to sell my products more but the reality
is there's no demand mhm so I don't
think that's a really good idea I don't
want to lend I don't want to borrow the
money which is why lowering interest
rates didn't work okay because no one
still wanted to borrow everyone was too
afraid right uh ultimately what happened
then is CEOs decided well wait a second
I can do something else with the money
MH I can borrow the money for free and
then buy back my stock MH okay now let
me explain this system because it's
essential to understanding where we are
and what's happening as we speak right
now uh buying back stock sounds
complicated to a lot of people it's
really not let's say that the the four
of us here are shareholders in a firm
okay each it's a million doll firm okay
each of our shares worth 250,000 MH well
if I'm the CEO and I have free access to
free money I can buy back one of the
shares
there's now three people sharing in that
same million doll company each share is
not worth 250,000 it's worth 333,000 and
to the CEO I say wait a second that's a
pretty good idea because I get paid to
see my share prices go higher so why
take risk with the money why do what it
was intended to do and stimulate higher
new people grow the business why not
just buy back stock yeah and so the boom
in equities over the last decade has
been largely fueled by stock BuyBacks
borrowing free money buying back the
shares and inflating the share price uh
and it's the it's the housing bubble all
over again uh only this time it's
incorporate debt in Corporate America
and it's been uh given in you know free
money by the Federal Reserve and I guess
as long as the debts being serviced
everybody's happy but when hard times
come and the debt doesn't get serviced
that's when
everything well yes is is a simple
answer um the reality is this uh that
Ponzi scheme can only last so long
because ultimately if I borrow money for
free I still have to pay it back and if
valuations come down at all well now I'm
stuck because I have all of this debt
and let me give you an example of what
that looks like see
the uh corporate borrowers borrow in
bonds okay it's a it's corporate bonds
MH the historical average return to lend
a uh junk bond or a less than perfect
credit company money is
12% okay so lenders got compensated for
that risk by lending to less to more
risky
companies uh with a higher interest rate
well here's what happens uh interest
rates come down to the floor Bankers are
trying to make fees they then start
offering lending to subprime companies
hey I'll give it to you for 10% I'll
give it to you for 9% I'll give it to
you eight 8% the junk bond rate now well
up until very recently as is now
starting to implode average 4% so as a
lender I'm now taking on massive more
risk getting a lot less return and then
what's also happened is the um uh the
underwriting of these bonds the uh
covenants for bonds has become very
loose so just like subprime lending
happened and it was stated income MH now
because Bankers are so eager to lend the
money and make the fees they're lending
to corporations and it's Covenant light
so Jeffrey gunak of double line Capital
who's known as the bond King thinks that
60% of the corporate bond market is
really subprime so we're right back in
it again well we're in in a subprime
credit crisis right now um and why uh
you're about to see a tremendous amount
of pain because this whole system is
built on Leverage so with the picture
you paint and it's certainly supported
uh I think you know really elegantly as
far as saying okay let's let's look at
Milestones along the way and how we got
here um and you're saying wow there's
going to be some
pain but if you're in gold and I guess
this is your thesis basically if if you
actually are in
Gold it's not going to be pain it might
be pleasure for you well well yeah so uh
the the question you have to think about
is what happens next and why does thing
why what what moves things okay see in
2008 we printed $4 trillion of money
there is an estimate on a white paper
done by the Federal Reserve that for
every percentage point away from 5% they
have to print somewhere between three
and5 trillion okay so in 2008 we had a
financial collapse they lowered interest
rates to zero and then printed $4
trillion and we reflate the economy well
right now well what do you think would
happened if they didn't do that what if
they said you know what this thing's
going work its way through we're not
we're not going to bail it out you know
and create all this inflation it's it's
the great question and probably we would
be in much better shaped than we are
today we would have probably suffered
through a much longer downturn MH but
the Reserve has bailed out of a very uh
what I believe is Criminal Enterprise in
Wall Street and what they did um you
know Wall Street knew they were taking
on uh these debts they knew they were
passing off bad debt to investors around
the world claiming it was uh you know
good debt investors really uh didn't
know what they were buying uh and the
bankers passed it off and got the risk
off their books in fact it's the the
whole story of The Big Short mhm Brad
Pit mhm um and uh you know they wouldn't
redeem the shorts until they got it off
their books and then of course they
allowed it to implode it's an
interesting thing because it sounds like
there's not a um they don't have the
stomach for a long longer term pain for
a true healing if you will they are just
going to like make it like a fake
healing of the economy through this
inflation which is destined just to
repeat itself again well is is that I
think I think uh an easy way to look at
it is see Mark we used to have a
capitalist system yeah okay our our
country is meant to be a capitalist
system right we really have socialism
for the wealthy right now because what
happens is all of that money went the
hands of a few MH and just to kind of uh
give you an overview of the new book uh
the great devaluation okay we have uh
this this this election is going to be
um a testament to the mismatch between
the Baby Boomers and
Millennials give you a quick example a
student right now um is paying interest
of 8% per year on their student loans MH
keep in mind um a few things you're
comparing these two generations okay and
and and what happens is every other
generation is a population boom mhm
every other generation is a population
uh less people so you have the Baby
Boomers which is the most populous uh
population in history up against the
Millennials who actually now have more
people than they do and the Baby Boomers
are leaving the system and the
Millennials are coming inh but here's
the system Millennials are coming into
okay in 1980 was when the Baby Boomers
hit their Peak earning years which are
about 36 to 50 mhm uh PE multiples in
the stock market were six times earnings
mhm interest rates were over 10% MH
today a millennial comes into this
environment Pete multiples are 30 times
earnings interest rates are at zero now
think about it if you're a millennial
and you're car I have a doctor M he's 32
years old he has
$250,000 in student
debt uh he says to me I'm I'm lucky I'm
only paying six and a half% on my debt I
said oh why is that lucky he said
because all my friends are paying 7 half
to 8% said okay um he said I'm really
excited because I'm paying down my debt
I'm finally making enough money to pay
down my debt um and here's the here's
what a guy like that has he can choose
to take he paid down his debt
$40,000 that 40,000 he could choose to
invest put it in the market but he have
to guarantee he makes more than 6 and a
half% and how are you going to make 6
and a half% when interest rates are on
the floor MH and this is the math
problem that Millennials are facing M
and I'll uh give you a opposite side of
that because the bankers uh Steve win MH
uh has a massive art collection uh Fine
Art much like housing prices have
exploded in the last 7 to 10 years and
what fine art uh buyers are doing is
leveraging their art able to borrow
against their value of their art which
has inflated over the last decade and
they're not paying paying 8% they're
paying one and a quar perc MH and what
are they doing with all the money
they're borrowing putting it back into
the stock market so you've got this uh
this divide between the wealthy and the
halves And The Have kns and this is not
capitalism this is not capitalism and
and this is this is one of the things I
think is really an important point
because some people say when they looked
at 2007 uh oh you see capitalism doesn't
work and and that was always my arum
said this is not capitalism
this is this is not a capitalist system
that's Market driven that that works
this is manipulation of a system and
it's really more socialistic than it is
capitalistic look if you have a Mercedes
and you have a car and you wear nice
shoes but none of it is something you
own it's all borrowed are you rich right
um you have nice things uh but does it
make you wealthy or Rich I don't know I
don't think so um we've bought borrowed
our way into Oblivion we have a national
debt that's at $23 trillion and and this
is the thing you know that it's really
very simple but I don't think it sinks
in very often the reality is that why
you know when you're buying cars you're
buying homes you're buying clothes all
the things you're talking all this
consumerism when you're doing all this
but it's done not because of you
production and value creation yes so I
think the the whole point here is that
we don't have a capitalist economy right
now
correct I would argue that the uh system
has benefited the wealthy at the expense
of the masses but that's not capitalism
no in in the sense that in capitalism
the markets are going to make all the
decisions about interest rates and
everything else and and it's about value
creation what we've got is consumerism
based on money that's created out of
thin air that's printed g out and as you
said oh all this money is available I
can buy my car I can buy my shoes I can
buy my house and the reality is that
that you know there's not the value
creation underneath it that supports all
these expenditures I think that's right
keep in mind we have no inflation
according to the Federal Reserve uh but
they're not looking at stock prices see
the one thing that's been purchased over
the last decade are equities yeah here's
the thing most people don't own equities
so the benefit of all of that inflation
of all of that valuation increase has
not hit the pocketbooks of mainstream
America it's all gone into the hands of
the few and uh ultimately when the FED
looks at these numbers they're not
looking at this and if you look at the
stock market uh and the fed's balance
sheet they go hand and glove so the more
the Federal Reserve has added to their
balance sheet the more stocks has risen
and it's all built on borrowed money MH
um and right now why that's a problem
see we're we're we're facing a couple
onew punch right now we have an oil
crisis at the exact same time as a
Health crisis if we were solvent okay uh
keep in mind if you uh have money saved
and you have an accident or you can't
work or you get sick it's not
necessarily the end of the world because
you can draw down on your savings right
uh we spent 1 .2 trillion more than we
brought in last year in the best economy
in history according to some statistics
MH so the question you want to ask is a
few number one if this is the best
economy of all time what are we going to
run in a less than best economy two
trillion three trillion four trillion
dollar uh deficits and I think the
answer is yes we have uh today the
Federal Reserve announced $1.5 trillion
of new money they're going to pump into
the system we're looking at a bailout
from fiscal expenditures through a tax
cut or some sort of uh you know
forgiveness of of extending the the tax
deadline uh it's going to be half a
trillion do and now think about it April
is when the treasury collects their
taxes $400
billion if they don't collect that 400
billion where is it coming from from so
they're going to have to borrow the
money and this is the entire Crux of the
argument treasuries have long been
considered the safest investment to own
okay this is the model own treasuries
because they're
safe well treasuries are now paying a
10e treasury is paying about half a
percent okay a 10 year the 10year
treasury is paying half a percent so for
the benefit of giving the government Al
loan you get half a percent per year and
you're lending to a government that you
know can't pay you back in fact the only
way they can pay you back is with
diluted dollars and that's why you want
to own gold because as the dollars
dilute gold prices go higher right so is
the stock market really doubled in the
last 20 years I don't know because our
our dollars have devalued six times so
really on a nominal basis the stock
market's down
dramatically uh and and this is really
the the secret that most people don't
know they plow their money into the
stock market and and buy stocks and
bonds because that's the tried and true
uh uh you know program okay uh in fact
we've been all know it you want to own
as many bonds as your age so if you have
if you're 70 years old you want 70% in
bonds 30% in stocks flip it around if
you're 30 years old okay well think
about it if stocks are at all-time highs
and bond are at alltime highs and
they're both at all-time highs because
of manipulated ultra low interest rates
uh number one how can owning them both
be considered Diversified yeah and if
there's problems with interest rates
which is what we found out in
2018 as the Federal Reserve tried to
raise rates it collapses the system so
now we're in a situation where the more
we grow the more we're going to owe so
interest rates that rise organically
make our costs go up even higher and
we're in a death spiral and the only way
out is a massive currency
devaluation so you're going to see the
dollar devalue dramatically in the
coming years uh in fact the only way out
of a debt crisis is to pay it back with
diluted dollars and that's why you want
to own gold and a lot of it right now
because that gold as the dollar devalues
will go higher in in in price and to
kind of bring you back to the question I
didn't quite answer about eating gold
okay and and the argument from Wall
Street I can't eat Facebook Amazon
Netflix or Google either and none of
them pay a dividend right so owning gold
is just like owning Facebook Amazon
Netflix or Google and the only reason to
own those is to sell them to someone
else for a higher price yeah the only
reason I think you want to own gold is
because you're going to be able to sell
it to someone else for a higher price so
yeah and so there's there's truly an
economic argument for gold not just a
preppers you know doomsday argument but
basically just saying hey you know
looking at the way things are looking at
the fundamentals of the economy this is
a really good place to place your your
your money and place a bed in this area
uh I think I showed you this on the
computer earlier I I built a site uh
Goldis better way.com and on that site
uh the entire premise of my first book
and the site is gold is better MH okay
it's outperformed the market since the
book was published Gold's up 32% the
Market's down
18% you're going to see gold outperform
the stock market 8X over the next s to
10 years and that's the premise of the
book is when you say do you you know I
put every penny in gold right now
because I know what's coming over the
next seven to 10 years we're about to
have an onslaught of monetary and fiscal
uh spending dollars are going to Deval
dramatically as that occurs and you're
going to see gold prices sore to unseen
Heights so give me a quick lightning
round now yeah so okay so now if you got
me convinced I want gold yeah uh I want
physical gold as compared to you buying
you know uh I guess what would the other
what would the other option be sure you
could buy uh ETFs that are back meant to
be backed by gold you could buy mining
shares and mining companies but you
wouldn't you would say that those don't
perform keep in mind my I talk to
investors who are long-term investors we
specialize in IRA and qualified accounts
these are retirement accounts uh people
should be looking at the marathon not
the Sprint so now if I so now if I've
got a retirement account I can buy gold
I can buy physical gold doesn't mean I
have to take delivery to my house it can
be stored in in a qualified location I
guess where it's held for me yeah if you
there's only two ways to own physical
gold MH one is with cash I can buy it
and have it shipped wherever I want and
put it in the ground or buried in my
backyard or under my bed if I want or I
can own it inside a qualified account uh
an IRA that's called a self-directed IRA
it's a special type of account and if I
own gold in that type of account it must
be stored at an IRS approve approved
depository yes so it goes there and uh
so people right now do you see a
movement going on I guess in conclusion
here do you think gold is a movement and
and people are going to start waking up
to you know the Dynamics of our economy
and and the flaws in it and that gold is
the place to go uh gold is at the
highest price point in every currency in
the world except the US dollar and it's
going there rapidly uh so this isn't a
movement that's new uh in fact uh you
know it's interesting the one asset That
central banks all own is
gold uh China's buying gold Russia's
buying gold turkeyy Buy buying gold and
they're all buying gold because they
know what's coming for the dollar it's
going to devalue and as the dollars
devalue their gold Holdings will be
worth more so it offsets that dollar
devaluation so the question I'd ask you
is uh if the central banks are owning it
and buying it why aren't you
yeah good question I think they know
what's going on more than just about
anybody else probably yeah well Adam
this has been fascinating your story is
fascinating the the story of you know
our economy over you know the century or
more is fascinating but uh the
conclusion you know I think you make a
really really uh profound argument for
why gold so uh you're you're the when
when we wanted to find out who do we
talk to about gold yours was the name we
were given so thanks for taking the time
and sharing oh it's been my pleasure
thank you so much Patrick
really your episode 7 bonus interview is
another one you should take notes on and
rewatch over and over Matthew Carr has
led thousands of his readers to outsized
gains from following breakout trends for
years and years today he's ready to
reveal the biggest investment Trend he's
following right now and show you how to
get in on it before the
[Music]
crowd
Matt thank you so much for being with us
hey thanks for having me so uh tell us a
little bit about who you are and what it
is that you do I'm the chief Trend
strategist for the Oxford club that
means that I um cover any sort of
emerging Trends I focus on cannabis I
focus on uh cryptocurrencies small caps
micro caps uh
nanox and I also look at seasonal
trading that's that's like my big bread
and butter I was impressed upon me when
I was a kid my dad used to say that
companies only made money 3 to 6 months
out of the year the rest of the time
they're just trying to uh Keep Their
Heads above water now we moved around a
lot very poor I ended up living in a lot
of Resort towns where everybody had you
know three to four jobs right you had
your summer job you had your spring job
you had your winter job and so when I
was when he kept telling me this I was
like well this is just for the
industries and and the areas that we
continue to live in but when I started
getting into finance and I started like
looking at companies and looking at how
their their revenue um was was was
shaping up that we I'd see the Sawtooth
pattern and you'd see the Sal trth
pattern in their earnings I was like
well wait here's this this this this
real thing that companies really do only
make money a couple quarters out of the
year the rest of the time uh they're
they're really just trying to to to keep
their head above water and try to make
sure that they're spending enough for um
the their biggest quarters you know
retail is the big one so I started in
investment strategy and and a system uh
built around that taking advantage of
that you could see the the the shares of
these companies would Peak during their
their best quarters of the Year let's
say like retail um on those fourth
quarter earnings they' they'd fly up
because that would be huge you can look
at the a chart of Macy's and see that
that is where all of its money is being
made right there in that that that
fourth quarter uh shares would fly on
that and so uh but then fall on Fourth
first quarter results when everything
looked terrible so this was a a trend
that I I I I saw and could take
advantage of and and that was how I
actually got started in this industry
and really sort of made my my a name for
myself by by targeting that and taking
advantage of these these uh
inconsistencies so Matt what's funny
about what you're saying as you say it
it is painfully obvious like I'm friends
with the guy who founded over stock.com
and I've watched them and you know like
their fourth quarter is everything and
yet like it's and I've never heard
somebody decide to do a seasonal trading
strategy it's like um a brilliant
obvious trend yeah so one of the things
that I did um that I really pride myself
on is we do a lot of research on term in
terms of not looking at earnings in a
horiz fashion so a lot of anist will say
well this company has missed earnings
you know three of the last four or two
of the last five or something like that
so what I do is I look at earnings in a
vertical fashion so I look at all first
quarter results all second quarter
results all third quarter and fourth
quarter and how shares responded to each
of those results uh for the last five or
10 years what happens is you can see
this really clear Trend that uh come
companies will will will Spike up on uh
let's say a fourth quarter result you
know Netflix is is one that's that's
huge right because one of the secrets
there is all of the gift cards for
Netflix that are given out no one can
account for that in subscriber numbers
so when Netflix reports fourth quarter
earnings it doesn't matter what their
revenue is or their uh earnings are none
of those companies uh care about that
what it is is those that subscriber base
and they always beat because of that
this this this ghost sort of sales these
these GI these gift cards but when you
look at all earnings and how uh how
shares react to each report like it it
it's a it's a very clear picture and
that's the the stuff that I love to take
advantage of that's the stuff that for
like options training is critical
because you can put uh you can buy a
contract on the backside of that report
make a lot of money let's identify
somebody that that this is for so it
this is for somebody you know that's
following your newsletters they're
actively trading in the market and and
you're bringing them a unique view of of
that maybe is outside what they're
normally hearing yeah and it's all uh I
generally hold stuff for three to to
nine months and I tell everybody that
when the dynamic fortunes uh publication
which which uses this system once you
start looking at this once you start
like going out and researching it you
will never uh do anything else you will
apply that to every other trading
strategy that you do and I actually do
it for all of my my my Serv I run checks
on this I run checks on how these
companies report uh respond to every
single report because there are very
clear Trends because the market is this
giant machine but
humans are this this underlying element
and humans aren't AR aren't totally
rational and so you're taking advantage
of that
irrationality um every single time this
is where I I remember being surprised to
learn that a stock has a life that is
separate from the company that sometimes
the company can do well and the stock
can do bad and sometimes this you know
the company can do badly and yet the
stock performs so I get what you're
saying and where you're looking at
how the stock responds to the the report
yeah because a lot of times that the
investors are looking at it sequentially
um so they're not looking at it so much
year-over-year so you can beat a year of
earlier maybe like 8% 10% growth but
that sequential increase is is probably
60% and that's something that that
everybody kind of like really latches
onto so you have a company that reports
250 million in the third quarter then
550 million in the in the fourth
investors cheer that because they're
like wow that's that's massive growth
but you know it's really maybe you know
5% just the swing just over year so you
mentioned like five things just right
right as you sat down cannabis
cryptocurrency so let's go through these
and and tell me what you're seeing right
now in in these well a cannabis well we
can start there that's something that
where we you just touched upon that
companies can do really well but the
stocks are doing terrible um I did
really well with cannabis in 2017 with
uh recommendations on a lot of the
Canadian LPS
this year uh has been much different
right uh this year I the the industry is
in the longest most um destructive bare
Market that it's ever suffered um in in
its very short time in existence so you
know cannabis has been trading for for
roughly three years uh we've had five
bare markets during that time so it's
not it's not it's not unusual to have
these bare markets it's a very volatile
sector but the one that we're currently
in now is just I mean this began in
March uh for for the Canadians uh April
for the for the US stocks and it's been
really devastating now all these
companies are reporting great
year-over-year growth in terms of
Revenue you are having losses though as
companies are are are spending more to
expand their operations right so so
that's the thing that's kind of like
hurting the stock but long term like
that is this this is a a fantastic play
this is you know five to 10 years this
is a great great opportunity because
never in in history do you have a $50
billion Market that's already in
existent right the the Cannabis the the
gray Market or elicit Market that exists
right now in the United States $50
billion once the the the US government
legalizes it at the federal level all of
that can be taken over by by these the
these private or or public public
companies so it's a fantastic
opportunity that's one I see as like a
really great play over the next several
years so let's look at the
cryptocurrency
okay and what are you seeing right now
well cryptocurrency has like is kind of
like the same thing I'll say that
cannabis feels like uh Bitcoin in 2018
so 2017 uh everybody was cheering as you
had these run up to
19,900 um and then 2018 just fell off a
cliff um I said it would go down to
$3,000 uh Bitcoin would go down to uh we
saw that uh the start of
2019 but this is the great thing about
Bitcoin at one point this year it was up
300% right uh was it was it was a really
great trade we're still up more than
100% at this point uh next year as we
head into 2020 you have the reward
having that is always another big driver
and catalyst for that so I think Bitcoin
is one of those areas that you really
have to watch going into 2020 because
once that happens we've seen in the past
that uh the price of Bitcoin has gone up
hundreds of percent to thousands of
percent so I'm I'm pretty much sure that
that's going to go to 14,000 maybe back
up to 19,000 next year so I hope so I I
bought it 3,000 so I was at and I felt
like I was late and I just decided I
should have some just and and I'm
promising myself to not look at it and
then when it went up to I think 12,000 I
started looking at it and now I have no
clue what it is today I don't care like
i' I've made a small bet there and um
but it sure was fun to watch a small bet
go uh well I'll tell you that that we I
knew the peak I was going to a cocktail
party and the coat check uh woman was
talking to us and she was like oh you
guys trade C cryptos she was like I own
uh Bitcoin and what's the other one like
light and ethereum and she's like I'm
doing great she's like I'm going to
retire off of it and I was like I'm
selling this is I saw this is the Sho
shine man on Wall Street uh in the you
know before the crash you know the the
story when when the the guy went and
sold all of his stocks after his shine
man was giving him a stock tip it's like
if it made it this far I don't need to
be in it and and that's one of the
things that I always keep a kind of
pulse on too I have a lot of friends
that are Traders a lot of friends um
Contex in industry that that invest and
when they start saying like oh it's like
printing money you know I'm doing
weeklys on on on Beyond me or I'm doing
weeklys on till Ray and I'm just
breaking in the dough and I'm like all
right well now I'm going to start
shorten
that that has never worked out so what
else what else are are trends that
you're watching for right now uh 5G is
the big one right so 5G is is this this
opportunity I think for where the
Internet of Things the industrial
Internet of Things things uh the fourth
Industrial Revolution all those
Technologies really come into play
because they need that bandwidth um
driverless cars um we already see that
driverless Vehicles exist in mining like
kamasu um the big um mining equipment
manufacturer that's something I've
always paid attention to over the years
because mining is is a great venue for
driverless Vehicles because you're just
doing the same route over and over so
they've been doing testing they've been
building out see more and more of that
come up so 5G I think is the big area
for the next um for the next year next
couple of years this is a $250 billion
Market just in the short term it's going
to impact probably more than a trillion
dollars worth of worth of uh um wow
stuff over the next couple of years so I
that's the big one I watch U and then
small caps I love like all kinds of
small caps by uh Nano caps micro caps I
look for all kinds of opportunities
there so if somebody's interested in 5G
how do you you know I I know that it's
going to be a wave but I don't know
where the wave exist so I I think the
the market itself got ahead of itself in
2019 every predicted everybody predicted
this roll out was going to be really
smooth that everybody's going to make a
bunch of money like Nokia um Cisco all
these companies um what ended up
happening all those sold off so I think
going into the next year you have a lot
of opportunities you can look at big
names you know like a Cisco like a Nokia
um even smaller names like you know crnt
you know sagon networks which are doing
back hauling um so I I think there's a
there's a lot of opportunities that
exist just over the next 12 months
because once that roll out hits once it
actually takes place this year you'll
see again that Revenue come into play so
for your
readers what do they um what can they
expect from you on a monthly basis you
know how many companies are you tracking
what are what um I track of hundreds of
companies so I usually give uh anywhere
between two to three recommendations per
month uh per service that I run so I run
free services um VIP trading Services uh
that each have their own individual
Focus so Dynamic fortunes does seasonal
trading uh treble Laser Pro does uh high
growth small caps and micro caps and
then um the Viper system focuses on high
growth um small caps that have been
beaten down so I'll do uh Viper we do
one pick a week right with options tribl
is a pro about a pick a week and then a
dynamic Fortune's two to three per month
um so I have hundreds of companies that
I track that have that have built
systems to to analyze and look at and
then I just go through and and kind of
pick like the best
uh
opportunities and like like I said
there's a lot of opportunities out there
uh one of the things that I'd love to
focus on is what I call 2020 small caps
these are companies that anybody can go
out and find so you're looking for 20%
Revenue growth 20% earnings growth um at
least and those are going to be your
great opportunities um because they have
a tendency to take off and really
Skyrocket and are they in a particular
sector is that Tech or is it what tech
is is is is very popular Tech and
biotech are are very easy um but you can
find ones in like energy you can look at
a company like a new Fortress energy
which is in LNG in Puerto Rico Jamaica
and Mexico here's a company that just
started trading 75% of Revenue growth in
the third quarter 100 plus per in the
fourth and when we look at the first
quarter of 2020 and next year 300 plus
per. right wow uh at the same time all
of its money that spent to build out its
operations are already in the books so
now it's going from let's say losing
a115 per share to actually a gain of
more than 34 cents so those I mean the
they exist across all kinds of things
all sectors you can look at retail you
can look at Tech you can look at um
cannabis obviously uh energy and how
heavily the options play into your
trading strategy okay so I'm I'm an
option Trad
by heart and I believe that options are
a great way to have a rocket boost for
returns so you can buy shares and maybe
the shares go up 20% but that underlying
option can go up you know 10 times that
amount and that's where you're going to
get those big gains so they always get
freaked out when people be like oh I put
$50,000 in this option like whoa whoa
whoa you know that's that's fine if you
want to take that kind of risk but you
know options are inherently risky
they're they're extremely volatile but
um I really like to take advantage of of
of that and those gains so actually hold
uh the record for the Oxford club for
the highest gain uh ever which was 2,700
on an option uh which we only held for
you know a couple months from Wow
October to February if somebody is new
to options but they have the right risk
profile they want to take some of their
money and and do options how do they
learn I guess how did you learn options
uh one you just kind of start going in
small right like you're nibbling at it I
I'll also recommend uh there's a great
book uh one of my friends Le L wrote um
getting rich with options that's a
fantastic book it's a great
title but but that he that teaches you
everything um he goes through you know
puts goes through calls um straddles uh
all that kind of stuff that's that's
more complicated so first is maybe paper
trading nibbling reading right uh I
always go uh there's a quote hold on
paper trading just so for somebody
watching it so paper trading means what
uh paper trading you're not actually
putting any money you're just getting a
feel for it got it that is one of the
best ways to learn we we all of the
people that we have that join our
company that are new to investing um
that might not be experts we make them
paper trade like every single Service uh
they start going out uh looking for
their own sort of options plays because
that's how the that's how you learn
right that's how you're going to learn
how it moves what it cost what your
risks are how much you're going to lose
and then we actually hold uh inhouse uh
competitions for like the best the best
paper trade the best paper trades uh so
paper trading is is is is a fantastic
place to start and then once you start
actually going out and making those
trades with real
money understand that especially in the
beginning that options move a lot lot
not in a single day but over months and
you can actually lose you know your your
entire portion that you invested in um
but you have to understand um that
volatility and embrace it so someday
you're going to be down 50% you're going
to be down 70% next day you'll be up 120
200% uh so you want to take gains uh
every time it doubles that's what my job
General Ru rule of thumb is once I get
100% plus gain I'll take half off the
table so then I'm just playing with
house money right if it doubles again
you know or goes up like 300% I'll take
another half off the table and then
continue doing that
until goes to expiration and if it goes
down just write it out yeah just write
it out um because you know this is
actually something that we kind of
talked about this week you know if it
goes down and and you're heading into
expiration and it's worthless and just
let it expire you save yourself the the
the the trading cost of commiss picking
up your four bucks so if if someone's
paper trading does does your newsletter
have any trading any options trading
training involved in it uh yeah I will
actually do um when you sign up for any
of my services I'll actually have like
an options like um sort of seminar that
I do several videos where I'll walk
through how to place a trade uh what it
represents you know because every
contract of an option is 100 shares
right so how you're going to calculate
your cost how you going to calculate uh
your return um your risks all that kind
of stuff so when you sign up I there's a
series that I do optimizing your options
which which goes through all of that and
breaks it all down so if somebody's
doing this and they have the right
temperament they like it and this is
something fun for them to do with a part
of their portfolio how much time are
they going to have to spend watching
this is this hours a day is this no no I
don't I don't do it hours day um you
know my rule of thumb is always um if I
don't if I'm not going to spend time
watching it or doing it or reading it
then I'm not going to expect somebody
else to do it so um if there's a video
that's too long let's say it's like you
know hundreds of hours it's going to be
very difficult for everybody to get
through that I've done the training
courses in the past and I know how many
people actually complet it um so I'll
try to keep it short tight um to the
point and as useful as possible um is
the thing you're most excited about
coming up is that 5G 5G uh especially
for uh 2020 that's one of the industries
that I'm most excited about that's you
know going to be our main focus um for
the year ahead um I'm also excited about
like I said cryptocurrencies Bitcoin
uh I think cannabis has a great rebound
year ahead of it everything's beaten
down to levels that you haven't seen
since 2017 so if you missed that runup
in 2017 you missed the runup in 2018 you
missed the runup in early
2019 now you're getting your another
opportunity to BU to buy in at those
levels and do you do you apply your
seasonal trading trading strategy to 5G
to to these things as well I I will as
much as I can because all these systems
they they sort of run and operate um I
create Trend profiles for hundreds of
companies I have a database of trend
profiles for for hundreds of companies
and so I will check all of these against
it if that if that if that data exists
um generally it has to be you know a few
years to get something reliable uh
because what the system also does is it
not only takes that historical data that
you can look at and see this trend but
then it builds AO profile for uh forward
projection prices right so uh one of the
things Dynamic fortunes does is when I
do like an options train I will actually
say what the potential projected price
Target is at that point because the
system will tell me exactly what it
believes it'll be right so then you it's
really easy to calculate your gains um
but I will run everything through that
system or or if I know a trend profile
exists for it I I'll I'll look at it you
know for for somebody who's who's
interested in you you know but you I I
don't want to sell a newsletter how can
somebody just follow you we not
subscribe or or buy anything but just
just follow you and see what you're
doing uh profit trends.com this is a a
website that I run and I'll do uh
several pieces a week I Mondays we do
beyond beyond the bong which is our
cannabis focused mailing I will give um
I give a Roundup of the week the the
last week and then I give what's the
high five and those are the five five
pot stocks to watch for the week ahead
um Tuesdays I do making the grade which
I will look at um I'll pick a sector or
or whatever I'm interested or whatever I
think people should know about and uh
that'll give like the 10 best stocks
that I think to to watch that you know
maybe they have uh biotechs that have
quadruple digit growth in terms of
revenue for uh for 2020 or the year
ahead um pot stocks that are over
overbought that are going to collapse or
uh biotechs that are overbought that are
going to going to collapse making the
grade on Tuesdays I'll go into all of
that research and I'll give 10 companies
to to to watch or avoid and um then on
Thursdays I do um an cannabis now or an
Biz now interview this is a video
segment about 8 to 10 minutes long where
I interview CEOs or uh Advocates
legislators um
anybody in the Cannabis industry that
has uh something of value to say we
interview them and that gives people
actually access to these cosos to hear
from from them about what's going on and
as well as medical professionals so we
actually had our Medical Professional
that we've worked with for the last um
couple years he said in October
2018 uh he would not use any vaping
device right like any any sort of vape
pen yeah because he he outlined all the
dangers that that existed and we saw you
know unfortunately that that that became
true um and then we do um a wrap up
every Saturday so if you don't want to
read all that stuff that
I that I put out during the week um we
do a wrapup on Saturdays and this is
free this is free okay so the website
again is profit trends.com I love that
you do this so I don't have to so really
appreciate you being here to day oh
thank you very much to see the next
episode in the wealth breakthrough
series check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I'm
standing there in the delivery room and
I've got my cell phone and I'm barking
orders into the the trading floor sell
sell sell at the same time I'm standing
there with my wife's right there in the
bed I'm saying push push push